how's it going bros my name is Pierre
welcome to octal that this game is quite
unique I'm gonna be honest I don't know
why I wouldn't be honest about that
yeah apparently you play as dad you're
an undercover dad best undercover ever
and you're actually an octopus but not
all right whatever I'm skip the ninja I
think I think I think about this game is
it the controller [ __ ] cop
but yeah you're actor Dan and you got
[ __ ] to do but it's quite difficult kiss
your [ __ ] octopus oh wow look around
your room
alright hold a knee to the right I got
it I'm gonna just go go and do some [ __ ]
over here oh wow it's a sausage oh no oh
no I am I our sausage I would if I could
climbed a wall no [ __ ] up my octopus I
should be able to clown a while all
right click the left bottom to raise him
I am doing it holy [ __ ] don't you think
I know how to walk I'm a [ __ ] octopi
oh man he's like no way I was gonna sing
Stane you're like but I started singing
wakin away downtown walking fast faces
pass and I'm hold down ok whatever walk
through the along alright I'm gonna do
that [ __ ] I'm a goat over my alarm clock
no problem alright just turn it off do
that [ __ ] all the day turning pressing
me am I about to switch to Hanselman
alright I got it
turn this [ __ ] off okay I'm not gonna
penetrate my own ass I'm just trying to
turn off the alarm
yeah Wow okay press the middle mouse
button
alright sleep them laughs miles managed
to grab our T's The Arbors I go green
will be the long you will grab all right
cool I will grab this base cuz I need
these face when I go to work alright
listen
yes yes then go pick up no no I always
had okay yes yes come on come to Papa
come to Papa
alright I wonder how he has sex oh let's
be quite the scene all right Preston
middle of us no I want this [ __ ] hat
no all right yes yes I got it it's
beautiful
let's throw it away Rob when you hold on
yeah he just did that Jesus all right
it's time to focus it's time we got to
work I am [ __ ] doctor that I got a
problem I'll [ __ ] [ __ ] you at
all right yes I'm working race arm to
hold right mouse button slide the mouse
forward and lower it decided back yeah I
get it okay yes let's go to storage and
shed because I need it
watch my [ __ ] grab the red makeup and
dryers alright let's try and do that
[ __ ] where's the red makeup
that's a fauna holy [ __ ]
why is the fire everywhere alright I
love spitting what are you doing we're
not to piss I don't understand I Jesus
Christ what am I even doing in this game
get the out of it I'm going all right
sorry sorry Safina alright the makeup oh
there it is there it is alright I'm
gonna do some [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] octopus
all right I'm going I'm going shot that
ash let's try that I don't even know
need to see where I go I'm just after
that you just cried alright there we go
alright grab my makeup and drag some
olives will give you suspicion oh yeah
you can't blow your cover that you're
off to that all their system is fishing
my eyes never sight you need to see the
controls again just hit escape in an
option alright I think I'm good I mean I
have [ __ ] I got my makeup a [ __ ]
all right I don't know what I'm doing
all right
no no grab the journal to end the Choya
let's gonna put this [ __ ] down and dr.
daddy's gonna penetrate this gentleman
know not to make a girl girl not makeup
girl okay oh you see that back flip
that was a snake now doctor thought it
was a dad no I'm not all right grab this
come on dude
yes yes no yes yes grab it grab the girl
you're so fine no yes I told him to that
[ __ ]
yeah all right look it's yeah Oh diary
hey I'm drinking houmous it's like the
first of the year I feel such a
Christmas thing I don't know if that's
only available in Sweden but joomla's is
[ __ ] awesome a lot of Dame's again I
have yet to be scoured my shallow pod
nature remains secret as long as I
acting normal farm or whatever shoot dad
suit doll distract wife escaped basement
need to finish a gift
boom happy Anniversary honey
[Music]
no oh I know you know what comes after a
romantic dinner octopus penetration
right she's a sicko like she could go to
jail Frank oh oh I Lois then all right
Fred's escape detector general hit the
shore time to get to low down on the
room all right I need to get bill that
mannequin I need a banana from the
kitchen a suit from the living room the
[ __ ] all right let's just go to Holly
here I'm off to dad got a problem with
me now [ __ ] you I'm on connect I'm his
house it's pretty cool
all right I'm gonna strut my way to get
jet no jet no I had to get strong yes
nope
dr. dan [ __ ] polish I'll claim that
[ __ ] I don't care
you know all right master bedroom no
that's not where we're going what about
this story
it doesn't say [ __ ] I need to go to the
kitchen dr. dan is going to the kitchen
why does - is this a kitchen no it's a
kitchen
jaesik penis all right I don't care I
don't care I don't care and I'm like dad
all right
why is the [ __ ] kitchen Oh God is ice
leaving the room why why is it kids
rooms everywhere
make some [ __ ] sounds master bedroom
kitchen
this is a kitchen Lee my opinion but all
right maybe it's the daughter that
doesn't have anything say huh all right
let's count I just count I need it
rabbit door handle right now now can't
credit rake the door handle I'll just
walk in no I can't do that ox dad called
octan please
why don't what the frickin frackin all
right let's go to room that's open now
all right Oh scary kitchen no no yes yes
Karen yes hello
you actually have kids you actually have
kids that's so disturbing I hadn't even
now
nice alright sure have a chance
yeah and that's how I attack Allah
understand is oblong oh of course
[Music]
okay I need a stomp the spring back
stays a book to read find out it's hard
to replace doll
swap oh god there's so many things you
dare I have uni cars and rain go tuck
your Doreen alright fine I'll do that
I'll do that [ __ ] alright let's go dad
yes yes that was easier yeah
I guess now but I need to go come on
sure I'll get you a [ __ ] air
wow this spoiled killed look at a room
oh there she is what do you want stop
the spiders from reaching your door I
don't see any spiders
I don't see she wants a unicorn spider
kids wanted on now the lap no got doubt
it cost me a million million it stopped
it was money everywhere no oh yes it can
open doors of course yes that's how I
open doors
yes no now I'm stuck
come on all right hi I'm uncle dad and
I'm on my way
yes I'm going after dad just going now
why oh there we go alright no let go
let's go that door okay I'm on my way to
another place yes another place I'm
going okay I'm not done here apparently
Oh God
I'm blowing my cover what's going on
sushi i love sushi octopus sushi then ah
now they found me what did they kill me
oh my dad's an octopus egg I can't all
right I can see if I ever give that
another try
I have everything if you want to and
I'll see you
[Music]
Laura Laura Laura Laura yes good job
Laura that's a real name he's like what
is T well